that's mr. Filip now because Joe is
there too he is small once Ana shows up
even Joe doesn't look back to all in
fact all three of them a tiny size is a
matter of perspective when we look at
the rainbow we see an endless spectrum
of colors to describe them we need to
put them into buckets purple blue green
yellow and red for a lack of
understanding and language we can't
describe and classify most shadings in
between people who speak a different
language therefore put each color into
slightly different buckets red means
different things to different people
colors are a matter of perspective our
first nine months were probably peaceful
then there was war but soon peace again
we grew up and there were struggles that
soon after led to friendships we grow
older and it gets difficult but then
also beautiful if we were to go back in
time and change one tiny detail
everything could have been different
Tim took a cookie and said he stole it
the teacher thinks that tim is bad his
dad said that he was just hungry
the economists professor thinks it was a
rational choice to maximize utility the
behavioral biologist believes that his
hormones drove him to do it and the
neuroscientist thinks it's his brain a
psychologist looked for the answer in
his past and the priest points to God
everyone has a perspective and no one
really knows Tim we all have different
genes and our own particular past
sometimes good and sometimes bad the
result is our own unique point of view
in this world even if we listen to the
same songs read the same books or smell
the same flowers these are not the same
songs books of flowers because what we
actually hear read and smell is our own
interpretation created by personal
memories and imagination
each book each song and each flower is
different to everyone of us everything
is a matter of perspective so when we
say this is good or that is bad we do
that from our own subjective point of
view sometimes it's better to be quiet
and to listen if someone is sad or angry
we can try to imagine how the world
looks from that person's point of view
maybe we can see what they see and
develop compassion maybe there is a
right or wrong a good or evil but maybe
there isn't
maybe all there is is compassion or
ignorance until proven right or wrong
let's be kind to each other
[Music]
you